[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
[Musique]
alors ce que vous venez de voir c'est
mon dernier record du monde en date 105
mètres sous la glace de cela que je les
canadiens le 8 mars dernier alors c'est
120 m 2 - presque que mon record
personnel en bassin j'ai nagé 221 m en
piscine c'est un record du monde
d'ailleurs à l'époque aussi mais qui n'a
pas été homologué pour cause de faux
départ malheureusement en tout cas là
c'était un vrai record homologué record
absolu d'une discipline qui compte pas
moins de trente pratiquant je crois dans
le monde
ça souligne un petit peu le le caractère
exclusif est assez marginal de cette
discipline d'apnée sous glace comme ça
en maillot dans cette eau à 20 degrés au
sein d'une discipline déjà assez
marginal qui hélas n'est un homme si ça
explose
ces derniers temps en tout cas ça a été
quatre ans de ma vie quatre ans de ma
vie pour pour préparer ce record d'être
né sous glace alors quatre ans de
préparation quatre ans d'entraînement
mais aussi je dois l'avouer quatre ans
d'appréhension et quatre ans de peur
voilà parce que un des premiers trucs
qu'on me demande évidemment si on me dit
waouh quel courage effectivement mais ce
que est ce que t'as pas eu la trouille
alors j ai évidemment je suis un être
humain
j'ai eu la trouille en revanche j'ai
choisi d'accepter
les risques à l'origine de cette peur
j'ai choisi d'accepter que le risque
fasse partie de l'aventuré c'est
exactement de ça dont je suis venu vous
parler ce soir parce qu est-ce que c'est
pas ça le courage in fine et un accepté
d'affronter ses peurs pour faire chacun
son propre record qui soit universelle
ou pas qu'ils soient du monde ou pas
qu'ils soient historiques ou pas peu
importe
alors
aujourd'hui
on vit dans un monde où le risque
n'existe pas on refuse catégoriquement
de s'engager
avec du risque la profusion de de
services à notre disposition notre
technologie notre génie ferait qu on
devrait vivre dans un monde zéro risque
et pourtant paradoxalement
on continue d'avoir peur même si tout
est à portée de clic dans son canapé on
continue d'avoir peur d'avoir cette
appréhension
alors je vous cache pas que moi aussi
j'ai tenté de minimiser les risques
autour de ce projet de records
je me suis préparée je me suis entraîné
avec beaucoup de préparation physique
beaucoup d'apnée évidemment au niveau en
piscine principalement parce que c'est
de l'amener à l'horizontale et non pas à
la verticale vous pouvez le voir
beaucoup d' acclimatation froid bien sûr
trois quatre cinq fois par semaine dans
une eau qui va entre 3 et 6 degrés 1
tout au long de l'hiver très épuisant
mentalement cette acclimatation froid
mais malgré cette préparation béton je
continuais d'avoir se doute alors je me
suis entouré d'une équipe
ma chef d'expédition chloé formidable
qui a été à la base de l'organisation de
tous projets
non kiné ostéo et ami vincent qui est de
toute mésaventure ma compagne évidemment
qu'ils aient le courage et de de
supporter toute cette pression pendant
pendant près de quatre ans une équipe
niçoise mon club d'apnée le cippa à nice
une équipe parisienne où je me suis
entraîné à apnée passion aussi sûr mais
sur mes allers retours entre nice et
paris une équipe savoyarde même où j'ai
terminé ma ma préparation dans lé lac
gelé de sa voix juste avant de partir au
canada et puis une équipe canadienne
vous l'avez vu dans la vidéo qui a été
extraordinaire sur toute la logistique
au canada d'outre-atlantique
et malgré toutes ces bonnes volontés
j'étais comme ça malgré tout c'est
toutes ces personnes bienveillantes qui
m'encourageait j'étais quand même
flipper
principalement autour d'un sujet
les réactions physiologiques
extrême
que provoquent les apnées prolongée dans
une eau glacée
j'ai pu ressentir à l'occasion de mes
plongée d'entraînement notamment en
savoie avant de partir au canada des
sensations très désagréable même après
mes apnée espèce d'inertie physiologique
où le corps se remet du traumatisme
qu'il a subie avec des vertiges des
arythmies cardiaques ont des trucs pas
très marrant et en plus de ça on sait
pas très bien pourquoi ça vient pourquoi
c'est là comme je vous le dis on est 30
à faire ça dans le monde donc c'est très
expérimentale au niveau de la physio et
niveau médical
alors je me suis quand même entourée
d'un médecin
cardiologue le professeur françois
raoult
et non par adulte
le mien est donc cardiologue à l'insep
et on a essayé de comprendre les
différences entre apnée à température
ambiante et apnée en eau glacée à 8
degrés pour le coup à la maison du hand
à paris leurs 8 degrés s'est pas encore
glaciale un c'est de l'eau froide l'eau
est considéré comme glacial en dessous
de 5 degrés mais là on a quand même
compris certaines choses quand même
compris certaines choses pendant deux
ans une fois par mois monitorer s'est
amené en eau froide on a compris un
petit peu les différences mais comme je
les dis on manque cruellement de recul 1
j'ai pas un million deux tennismen qui
sont passés avant moi sur un une
tendinite du coût d'un nom qu'on sait
pas vraiment quels sont les risques on
sait pas comment les prévenir vraiment
sais pas vraiment comment intervenir en
fonction ce qui se passe on est un petit
peu dans le flou j'étais vraiment
pionnier en terre inconnue dans ce dans
ce record d'apnée sous glace alors
malgré cet accompagnement médical
j'étais quand même comme ça
alors je me suis repassé les bienfaits
de l'apnée les bienfaits de l'eau froide
aussi pendant quatre ans je me suis et
ressasser ça dans la tête
l'apnée véritable sport thérapie vous en
doutez peut-être qui est en train
d'exploser en ce moment on n'a plus un
club on n'a plus une piscine municipale
pardon apparu il ya pas un club d'apnée
ça explose complètement des bienfaits
sur le physique évidemment en âge on
s'entretient des bienfaits sur la
physiologie on améliore le transport de
l'oxygène on améliore la tolérance au
co2 des bienfaits sur la balance psycho
émotionnel je dirais c'est à dire le
contexte les facteurs contextuels de la
pratiquant le contact avec l'élément la
pesanteur le silence la glisse et c'est
donc vraiment un sport complet
l'eau froide d'un autre côté miraculeuse
au froid d'un très connu dans les pays
du nord depuis longtemps mais qui
commencent aussi à arriver chez nous
avec des effets incroyable sur le
système cardiovasculaire
la santé du système cardiovasculaire le
système immunitaire en plus malade quand
on se met dans l'eau froide les douleurs
chroniques la récupération musculaire çà
c'est bien connu des sportifs depuis
longtemps la qualité du sommeil tout ce
qui est inflammatoires et caetera et
caetera et j'en passe mais alors tout ça
c'est vrai effectivement ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne très bien je peux vous
l'assurer mais ça fonctionne à un niveau
loisir
et c'est comme dans tous les sports 1
une randonnée dans la dans la vallée des
merveilles dans l'arrière-pays niçois
c'est très sympa ça a l'air le corps
s'avère l'esprit mais quand on part à
l'ascension du k2 on a une chance sur
trois dit rester
un footing entre copains c'est sympa un
marathon des sables c'est le challenge
d'une vie d'accord c'est exactement
pareil dans l'app n'est l'eau froide à
un niveau loisir c'est agréable ça
entretient à un niveau extrême et ben il
ya une prise de risque évidente alors
malgré ça malgré mes certitudes sur ses
activités eh bien je continuais de
d'avancé avec cette boule au ventre
que j'ai traîné jusqu'au canada ce
boulet que j'ai traité jusqu'au tanner
pardon jusqu'au canada sur place sur la
glace de la carrière morrison au québec
où là pour continuer d'essayer de me
rassurer et d'essayer de minimiser les
risques autour de ce projet
eh bien je me prépare pendant deux
heures avant de plonger deux heures à
travers lesquels je vais
passer par une première phase de
visualisation je marche le long de ce
trac qui a été construit pour moi sur la
glace sur 105 m je marche le long et je
me vois comme ça nage est passé à
travers ces issues de secours qui ont
été faites tous les 20 mètres et je
m'imagine les sensations qui vont qui
viennent plus ou moins agréables la zone
de confort l' envie de respirer qui
arrive la zone de travail la sortie la
valeur de la validation du protocole de
sortie devant le juge et c'est tout ça
est très très codifié un bien sûr
une fois que c'est fait je vais dans une
tente qui a été dressée sur le bord du
lac pour moi qui est chauffée à 35 40
degrés à peu près là je m'équipe et je
me charge en chaleur le chargeant
chaleur je mets mon baudrier une petite
ceinture en nylon malines m'allonge qui
sera accrochée la ligne de vie dans
l'eau mon bonnet mon masque ma montre
mon maillot
évidemment est au dessus de sa j'enfile
donc madrid rome cette grosse parka
rembourrés que vous avez vu parka noire
qui maintient tout ça au chaud une fois
que c'est fait je migre dans une
deuxième tente qui étaient dressées tout
près du point de départ qu' elle n'est
pas chauffée là il ya un lit de camp et
je vais rentrer sur ma dernière phase de
préparation d'un à face préparatoire
avant de partir
sous la glace cette phase ça va être sur
ce lit de camp allongé des exercices de
ventilation de concentration et des
exercices d'apnée bien sûr de rétention
de souffle qui n'ont qu'un seul but
c'est augmenter un maximum la zone de
confort pendant la performance augmenter
un max repoussé par dont un maximum lé
envie de respirer le plus loin possible
à des exercices spécifiques
d'acclimatation co2 qui permettent de
repousser l'envi de respirer parce que
je suis un apnéiste contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire qui a envie de
respirer très vite et très fort
d'ailleurs mais c'est pas forcément un
inconvénient
une fois que c'est fait je sors de cette
de cette tante je m'assois sur sur la
glace je me déshabille je suis en
maillot les jambes qui étrangement cette
eau glacée à 0 à 4 degrés
et là j'ai toujours cette appréhension
je me glisse dans l'eau la punissent de
sécurité clip m'allonge à la ligne de
vie
la voix du juge résonne dans ma tête
deux minutes compte à rebours une 45 une
30 une 15 je suis totalement lâché un
set préparation m'a mis dans un état
quasi hypnotique
mais je suis toujours comme ça
et là
45 secondes avant le départ
après m'être traîner cette appréhension
pendant quatre ans presque
d'un coup je choisi
d'accepter ce qui peut se passer sous la
glace
je choisi d'accepter que le risque fait
partie de l'aventuré
que cette part d'inconnu incompressibles
malgré tout ce que j'ai mis en place
pour essayer de la réduire au maximum
persiste quoi qu'il arrive
je me gonfle le top 0 arrive
et je m'élance
la contrôle total contrôle total sur les
20 30 premiers mètres je suis dans ce
qu'on appelle le flou vous savez chez
les sportifs degré de concentration
ultra élevée j'ai accepté la peur elle
n'est plus là il ne peut plus admettre
un plus je m'aime pas à ce moment là
encore trop atteints par le froid jeune
âge et je plane au dessus de ce câble
guide j'ai un câble guide en dessous de
moi qui me montre le chemin
et là pendant une vingtaine trentaine de
mètres tout va absolument bien à 20
mètres 30 mètres l'envi de respirer
commencent à pointer le bout de son nez
un l'eau froide donne envie de respirer
très très vite
et là je rentre dans la phase de travail
qui va durer jusqu'à 80 m à peu près
qu'ils la fassent d'appui difficile
parce que on a déjà envie de respirer
même assez fort en envie de respirer
montrait très vite et puis il reste
énormément de temps à parcourir on est
encore loin de l'objectif
est là le but c'est de ne pas accélérer
rester concentrer sur la technique
déconnecter le plus possible cerveau de
l'épreuve qu'on est en train de vivre
et continuer coûte que coûte on
débranche le cerveau complètement c'est
vraiment en exercice de détachement
et finalement mètre après mètre la
barrière des as barre des 80 m arrive je
la dépasse et là vous savez c'est comme
un marathon c'est pas les 200 derniers
mètres les plus difficiles c'est entre
le km 20 km 40 que c'est horrible partir
du kilomètre 40 et 2 derniers kilomètres
c'est comme ça voilà c'est exactement
pareil je fais les quelques brasses qui
me séparent de la sortie c'est toujours
très difficile mais mentalement c'est
redevenu moins difficile il reste que
quelques mètres à parcourir je sors je
valide ma performance le juge me montre
la wild card on se prend dans les bras
en hurlant c'est magnifique la gêne ni
la peur et l'appréhension
chaos j'ai converti même cette peur en
réussite et ans et en bonheur je dirais
alors moi je les fais à travers une
discipline extrême je vais faire un
trajet fait à travers de l'apnée des
records d'apnée en eau glacée sous 50
centimètres de glace mais j'ai pas
commencé comme ça j'ai commencé en
inscrivant dans un club j'ai commencé en
découvrant l'apnée en apprenant à
respirer en m'inscrire dans un club en
piscine en région parisienne d'ailleurs
et puis petit à petit j'ai commencé à
faire des compétitions et puis in fine
et j'en suis arrivé à faire des
championnats et enfin déjà organisé mes
propres records d'apnée sous glace
l'important dans ce que non ce que je
veux dire là c'est qu'il faut apprendre
à commencé petitement a commencé
petitement et humblement
alors moi je les fais à travers ce sport
extrême mais ma question c'est vous
évidemment comment est ce que vous allez
commencer à sortir de votre zone de
confort messieurs dames est ce que c'est
en chaussant vos running pour un premier
footing est ce que c'est en allant
parler votre supérieur d'un projet qui
vous tient à coeur directeur financier
que sais-je à vos proches pourquoi pas
d'un sujet qui fâche
peut-être à oser aborder cette jolie
brune ou ce beau blond à la machine à
café à la pause peu importe en réalité
l'important étant de se mettre en action
pour sortir de sa zone de confort au
début ce abominablement difficile
je le reconnais et puis petit à petit
quand on commence à ressentir les
bénéfices
que ça apporte autant dans les réussites
que dans les échecs d'ailleurs tant pis
si elle dit non il dit non c'est pas
grave la suivante dira peut-être oui
d'accord l'important étant évidemment le
bénéfice que ça apporte d'un point de
vue de l'enrichissement personnel de
l'expérience et du parcours d'accord
alors
est-ce que c'est pas ça le courage in
fine et
accepter les risques inhérents à chaque
entreprise
pour devenir acteur de sa destinée pour
devenir acteur de son existence pour
devenir soi-même réellement
authentiquement est soi même devenir
ensuite un modèle de motivation pour les
autres boucle est bouclée
cette capacité à s'abandonner aux
risques c'est cette capacité à s'en
remettre je sais pas peut-être à quelque
chose qui nous dépasse un peu à croire
en sa destinée à croire en quelque chose
qui nous transcende quelque part parce
que je pense qu'il ya un petit peu de
spiritualité là-dedans presque je crois
que ce concept beaucoup des gens des
grands personnages qu'on a aujourd'hui
comme modèle elle avait tout à fait
compris moi je pense évidemment à
jacques mayol pour prêcher pour ma
paroisse le héros du grand bleu
l'apnéiste mais voilà je pense que plein
de grands personnages d'aventuriers de
scientifiques de sportifs etc avaient
tout à fait compris ceux ce concept
moi je crois l'avoir compris à travers
mon sport mais ma question évidemment
c'est vous qui m'avez écouté vous quel
sera votre propre record je remercie
[Applaudissements]